you've really honest in this book - not
that you haven't been in the past but I
was really shocked to read because when
Leonard Nimoy passed away originally you
had said like I have a charity event I
couldn't make it and I guess you would
just kind of keep the peace there what
happened with you and him because I was
shocked to read that you had a kind of
falling out with him yes I don't know
what happened all I know is that I had a
charity event for his funeral I couldn't
go to the funeral but I I'm not sure
that would have been welcome at this
funeral anyway but I couldn't go to the
funeral and I and what I did do though
what I told the audience
it so happens at mar-a-lago Red Cross
there were we raised millions of dollars
for the Red Cross that evening what I
did say to the people at the event was
that all our names and fame and all that
disappear so rapidly that it's
unconscionable within weeks days months
certainly years the most famous of
people are gone and forgotten what is
not forgotten our good deeds because
they reverberate they don't have your
name attached to it but if you help
somebody and that person helped somebody
else that butterfly wing effect takes
place and for the rest of time that good
deed continues to resonate but he
stopped talking to you for some reason
yes I don't know why and did you is
there it has what point did he yeah
about a year before he died do you just
out of nowhere then so I mean that's
years after you've worked together I
mean you had this relationship your
friendship yeah now is there always a
friendship or was it casual because no
we had so much in common we our lives
was strangely born four days apart he
was in Boston I was in Montreal very
similar cities he got married about the
same time divorce children of the event
the major events of life happened to him
as happened to me and we helped each
other was there anybody and his family
was I know if his wife is still living
moves or anybody you could have asked in
his family who might have known uh yes
and never got a satisfactory answer
really what would they tell you well
because it's not talked to his son and
madhu really quite no and and he had
stopped talking to his son for a while
so oh wow it was it was mysterious and
maybe there's something on I've ceased
to examine that be sure really no answer
and I've left I've let go of it does it
bug you that there are people like
George Takei for example has kind of
pushed this narrative that you're a
difficult guy right he said negative
things about you for a lot of years no
for since the beginning of this guy 55
years ago I there I worked with this
gentleman a day here and a day there I I
don't know him right and ever since that
moment nothing untoward ever happened I
didn't kick him in the balls or anything
[Laughter]
what problem is he's bespoke Boreas
spoken badly of me right for fifty-five
satisfactory answer and and and it just
keeps you know he defames me and I said
I keep trying to rise above it but I'll
have to kick him in the balls
time you actually saw him in person like
as close as you and I are maybe ten
years ago at an event and did you speak
pleasantly or not at all and nodded in
his direction and he trembled a little
one more gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests any
I'm on demand using the SiriusXM F
[Music]